.
>> HOW MANY ISIS-K PRISONERS
WERE REMOVED AND WHY WENT THEY
MOVED TO GITMO?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
NUMBER.
IT'S IN THE THOUSANDS.
>> U.S. OFFICIALS SAY REPORTS
THEY SHARED LISTS OF AMERICANS
AND AFGHAN ALLIES WITH THE
TALIBAN ARE INCORRECT.
IN SOME CASES TO GET THE AFGHANS
THROUGH A CHECK-POINT THEY
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION AND THE
TALIBAN LETS THEM PASS.
>> THE NOTION WE ARE PROVIDING
THEM WITH NAMES OF INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE MAY STAY BEHIND OR EXPOSE
ANYONE TO ADDITIONAL RISK IS
FALSE.
>> THE PENTAGON DENIED REPORTS
THAT THE TALIBAN ALREADY ENTERED
THE KABUL AIRPORT.
>> HAVE THE TALIBAN TAKEN
CONTROL OF ANY PART OF THE HAMID
KARZAI AIRPORT?
>> NO, I SAW THAT REPORT TOO.
IT'S FALSE.
>> AS TO WHY THE U.S. DIDN'T
SEND ISIS-K TO GITMO, THE ANSWER
FROM THE PENTAGON THEY THOUGHT
THE AFGHAN ARMY WOULD WATCH
THEM.
SOME OF THE C-17 PLANES WERE
MEDAL OF FREED